What second season does he not want to watch?
Well that second season is....
The second season of Ore no Imouto.
What was that ending? This has to be the most dissatisfying ending I've ever watched in anime.
*Loud Ass Noises*
*Untranslatable Rage*
*More Loud Ass Noises*
If you like Ore imou as much as I do, you're probably going to be disappointed.
Unless you like incest. Then you're just freaking weird.
♪Push it to the limit♪
This show is just like... he wants to fuck his fucking sister man...he just really wants to..he really does.
*Intense Anime Girl Screeching*
[In Japanese] Dicks.
[In Japanese] I love them!
♪ Open up the limit♪
♪Past the point of no return♪
Inside here is a huge variety of manga porn.
Chris Hansen!
Sir, why don't you take a seat?
[In Japanese] I've seen a dick before, too!
♪Hit the wheel and double the stakes♪
It's off the scale!
Do you know what I'm saying?!
Off the scale!
You have to let it all go you know?
*Even More Intense Anime Girl Screeching in the Background*
Sin. Doubt.
*Intense Anime Girl Screeching Continues*
*Accurate Reaction to the Show*
♪Welcome to the limit♪
(♪Limit♪)
♪Take it baby one step more♪
IS ThaT A JOjo ReFEreNcE!?!
♪The power game's still playing so♪
♪You better push it to the limiiiiiiiiiiiii♪
(♪The limit♪)
♪iiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiii♪
♪iiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiii♪
(♪The limit♪)
♪IIIIIIIIIIIIIIIIIIIIIIIIIIIIIIIIIIIIIIIIIIIIIIIIIIIII♪
(♪The limiiiiiiiiiiit♪)
(♪The limit♪) (♪The limit♪) (♪The limit♪)
♪IIIIIIIIIIIIIIIIIIIIIIIIIIIIIIIIIIIIIIIIIIIIIIIIIIIIIT♪
(♪The limiiiiiiiiiiit♪)
♪Push it to the limiiiiiiiiiiiii♪
♪iiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiii♪
(♪The limit♪) (♪The limit♪) (♪The limit♪)
♪IIIIIIIIIIIIIIIIIIIIIIIIIIIIIIIIIIIIIIIIIIIIIIIIIIIII♪
(♪The limiiiiiiiiiiit♪)
*Starts to Fade Out*
♪IIIIIIIIIIIIIIIIIIIIIIIIIIIIIIIIIIIIIIIIIIIIIIIIIIIII♪
(♪The limit♪) (♪The limit♪) (♪The limit♪)
There's a story in my eyes...
Turn the pages of d-